ich finde einfach die miley hat sich
sehr sehr heftig verändert und nicht nur
miley sondern auch ein paar andere leute
der szene beziehungsweise youtube hey
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren video und zwar wollte ich heute
mit euch überall so ein paar meine
finger macht geknackt um sprüche fakt
ist vielleicht weil es nicht und die
brechen irgendwann jetzt richtig gut
nein ich nehme das jetzt einfach so als
pächter hat sich in meinen fingern und
zwar wollte ich heute bei den absturz
von stars reden bzw
am beispiel von 1 unter anderem miley
cyrus und eventuell auch ein paar andere
stars es können ja auch youtuber oder
sowas ein die wie ich finde sich
eventuell ein bisschen verschlechtert
haben durch sehr große resonanz sehr
große aufmerksamkeit sehr großes
medieninteresse und medienpräsenz und
allgemein über das sind wie ich damit
umgehen so was alles weil ich finde
allgemein durch diese sache mit miley
cyrus was er jetzt den medien war werde
ich euch gleich mal erklären was da war
und jetzt nochmal so dass ganze die
ganzen pressen berichten quasi über
diese aktion von miley cyrus und
zweifache ich jetzt erstmal was da war
ihr könnt doch einfach einfach nur miley
cyrus news oder miley cyrus awards
eingeben bei
link booms bei youtube oder bei google
keine ahnung er wertete schon werdet ihr
schon finden jedenfalls war da diese wm
putin das war irgendwie sonst so eine
wort oder irgendwie sowas keine ahnung
wo man halt preise gewinnen konnte für
video music award kann ich glaube in so
was war das er ist auch egal dass es für
eine wortwahl jedenfalls hat miley cyrus
seine performance hingelegt mit robin
thicke ich weiß nicht ob der fake heißt
oder kicker sind ist fix
th ck ausgesprochen wird aber dieses mal
gilt dieses lied auch keine ahnung
ihrerseits aber darum geht es auch gar
nicht
und zwar eine performance mit dem
hingelegt und die war halt sehr
grenzwertig von der liebe miley cyrus
und zwar hat die da unter anderem ja
schon in einem musikvideo damals immer
so für schlagzeilen gesorgt wo sich da
zum beispiel die finger abgekartet hat
und obwohl das eigentlich für kinder
unter anderem auch gedacht war und so
was alles das mit dem finger am platz
war extra schlecht aber die wurde halt
auch dann in der presse spekuliert was
das denn sollte und das meinte dann auch
jetzt mittlerweile drogen
beziehungsweise schon seit längerem und
das jetzt alles rausgekommen sind
irgendwie so tabletten dass es damit
droht kenne ich gar nicht ich weiß ja
gar nicht wie die heißt jetzt nicht dass
ecstasy nein wenn ich das schon höre
höre wie marihuana oder lfd
nee das ist irgendetwas anderes keine
ahnung nicht dass dieser standard krams
jedenfalls jedenfalls ist halt bei miley
dann auch hat sie dann gefragt vor allem
hat sie glaube ich sie hatte so einen
riesen handschuhe an ihn kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich aus irgendwelchen
football spielen oder sowohl in amerika
wenn man solche riesen handschuhen die
dann die leute anfeuern und sogar auf
rupert geknackt auf dem spielfeld mit
ihrem zweiten hand schildern zu
hochheben und zeigen somit fing alles an
den hatte sich erst mal damit hat sie
diesen robben seine blieb gefasst
das war aber nicht ganz so heftig
sondern mehr heftig war auf einmal fängt
man an zu wirken was trocken ist also
twr ki in networking könnt ihr einfach
auch mal youtube bzw
googeln wer das nicht weiß sollte man
eigentlich mittlerweile wissen wenn man
in der internet welt lebt im internet
jedenfalls hat sie das halt gemacht erst
mal mit ihrem prallen arsch vor der
ganzen masse und damit ihren prallen an
den prallen eiern von robin vik und der
typ ist verheiratet sie haben nur noch
habe ich noch ein kuss auf die wange
gegeben und was also keine ahnung was
das alles soll solche performances ich
weiß nicht ob das in medien trägt warum
die da nicht schlagzeilen zu kommen oder
so aber sowas finde ich zum beispiel
einfach nur ermutigen das habe ich mich
fremd einfach vor allem was aus dieser
miley cyrus geworden ist die damals
dieses dings wäre diese hannah montana
schauspielerin da ganz brav und hat tage
arbeitet als schauspielerin im interview
ja eigentlich wollte tiere als den
behörden aber jetzt bin ich als
schauspieler und sowas alle sind jetzt
wirklich so abgesagt es ich weiß dass
man das als da nicht verhindern kann das
sieht man auch am beispiel justin bieber
zum beispiel der nimmt sich ein bisschen
so allerdings kann muss man eigentlich
respekt vor seiner leistung haben weil
das was er geschafft hat es wird keiner
von uns je erreichen in seinem ganzen
leben dass wir auch in die nächsten jahr
nicht passieren
wegen dem menschen auf dieser welt
deswegen kann sollten das eigentlich
respektieren allerdings ein verhalten
letzter zeit wo man dann halt paparazzis
umfährt da wo man zum beispiel auch
einfach drogen nimmt und das direkt vor
einem bühnenauftritten dann auf der
bienen zusammenklappt also keine ahnung
verstehe ich nicht so was ist halt würde
einfach der stress den dazu kopfe steigt
und dass es bei mir mittlerweile auch
schon preise nicht dass ich irgendwie
druck nehme bevor ich aufnehmen nein
ganz im gegenteil
ich bin eigentlich so immer so witzig
drauf oder nicht meine mutter was ins
getränk punkt ab bleiben ein keine
ahnung m
jedenfalls ist es bei mir so dass der
ganze stress mir zu kopfe steigt das
habe ich auch bei simon festgestellt
beziehung hat sie mir auch gesagt weil
wir halt immer konfrontiert konnte
wir werden hat immer konform zu dumm
einfach wir werden halt immer
konfrontiert mit verschiedenen
kommentaren
so macht man dies machen wir wieder da
was von der serie und warum kam halt der
mega projekt also ein paar sachen die
sind halt bei uns auch schon so ruhig so
nach dem motto so ein paar sachen wir
freuen uns natürlich über alle
kommentare und auch wenn ihr sowas fragt
das heißt dass ihr das irgendwie merkt
oder irgend sowas beziehungsweise das
feiert oder ihr wollt neues video im
neuen disk zu geben keine ahnung
getaucht sein ich liebe euch alle
in fetten lecken über eure lange in euch
alle
nein jedenfalls sollte man da jedenfalls
sage ich hier sehr oft jedenfalls ist es
jedenfalls eine sehr interessante
tatsache die ich jedenfalls jetzt
erstmal wieder legen werde
da ich jetzt nicht den satz mit
jedenfalls anfang aber jetzt jedenfalls
wieder im satz gesagt habe aber das ist
jedenfalls mir jetzt erstmal jedenfalls
relativ egal
es hat allerdings zur folge dessen dass
wir dann halt übels viel stress haben
weil wir das aufnehmen und das aufnehmen
dann das gehalten und vor allem zum
planung mit dem neuen projekt wenn man
mit surfer typen quatschen muss ich
möchte jetzt gar nicht mehr verraten und
mitspieler raussuchen muss und regeln
und alles und sie mal gesagt dass den
und ich dabei sein werden und wir planen
dass alle so zu dritt und so weiter und
so fort also das ist eine menge stress
vor allem video day wo man beim video
day nicht mal eine minute rumlaufen kann
ohne dass leute um einen herum stand und
autogramme wollte man nicht durch kann
mir das so fett war
ich wollte einfach nur ich kam vom
bahnhof und wollte zum video der stand
gehen wo sie mann und den saßen und kev
und rotwild und jedenfalls ich geh dahin
und auf dem weg verdrängen mich so viele
leute und ich hab einfach zehn minuten
gebraucht um bis zu diesem blöden stadt
zu kommen
das so heftig das war einfach nur sagen
jetzt einfach für alles was so nö so
scheiße oder so sagen einfach das ist
einfach nur also wir sagen aber das ist
einfach nur weh hahaha also w h h sowie
ok schreibt dass man alle in die
kommentare der gartenseite thh also
ausgesprochen aber geschrieben oder
halt dein maul sowieso keine ahnung wo
auf was für telekom ist an 20 vor
einzelner nacht am 28 08 08 in der nacht
am 27 08 00 uhr rapid die folge direkt
am 28
direkt heute hochladen werden also doch
aber ihr wisst was ich meine ich lieber
nein ich liebe euch irgendwie sehr oft
in diesem video egal ich liebe euch
jedenfalls möchte ich nur sagen dass mir
dieser druck aufgefallen ist bei einigen
youtube unter anderem zb habe ich jetzt
letztes erst ausgefahren dass patti
katar haben und schneide typen und leute
die den film und alles und das die fast
nichts mehr selber machen
ich mein ich weiß die haben ne menge
druck die sind schon zweimal bei tv
total die geben interviews die sind da
zu gast dann sind sie dabei ich fand
alles mögliche die haben übels viel
stress das weiß ich sowas respektiere
ich auch und ich mag die jungs auch
eigentlich so vom äußeren ich hab dir
ich habe die noch nie so herzig habt ihr
schon getroffen und zwar noch nicht so
länger mitgeredet
jedenfalls möchte ich dass es bei mir
halt nie so wird deswegen möchte ich
eine one-man-show hier ist so mehr oder
weniger bleiben auf einem kanal
deswegen mache ich auch let's play weil
man da halt alles selber mache ich mache
alles selber um einen kann ich meine
designs selber ich mache meine sampl
selber ich mache die beschreibung selber
ich beantworte kommentare selber
verwalte mein facebook twitter selber
das ist alles von mir und da will ich
jetzt noch mal darüber geredet haben
dass ich auf jeden fall versuche auf
alles einzugehen allerdings ich manchmal
mit dem druck einfach nicht hinterher
kommen ich denke so ist es auch bei
stars wie zum beispiel weil die cyrus
justin bieber zum beispiel auch simon
oder halt ungespielt wählen kennt oder
auch wti dass man einfach nach gewissen
zeiten hinterher kommt und sich
prioritäten setzen muss natürlich ist
youtube meine priorität über alles aber
darüber
über youtube kommt natürlich noch
familie schule laufbahn das in die drei
punkte die noch darüber sind und ja auch
freunde
jedenfalls sollte ich das schon ganz gut
sagen dass ich versuche mir selbst treu
zu bleiben und mich nicht durch den
stressigen die runterlassen kriege
unterkriegen lasse deswegen inflation
ich bin in dem video grad einfach gut
drauf und ich mache auch nur videos wenn
ich gut drauf bin deswegen lachen leute
in letzter zeit oft wenn sie mit mir
aufnehmen wenn ich dann einfach gut
drauf bin weil ich zeit habe ich ab
ferien als ziemlich alles ist still ich
hab studienplatz wahrscheinlich safe ich
habe wahrscheinlich eine wohnung safe
und so was alles ich habe sogar noch ein
jahr schule und hebt das schon alles von
daher bei mir läuft im moment einfach
bei mir läuft
naja leute jetzt wisst ihr auf jeden
fall was ich zu der sache mit miley
cyrus bei den awards um zu justin bieber
denke und ich finde einfach die miley
hat sich sehr sehr heftig verändert und
nicht nur miley sondern auch ein paar
andere leute der szene bzw youtube und
das sollte jetzt einfach mal sagen nicht
zum schlechten sondern auch teilweise
zum guten und ich will damit nicht simon
ansprechen ich mag sie noch nicht dass
einige denken dass ich jetzt ihm wie
sieht man oder wollte die dessen werde
ich meinen allgemein so in der medialen
präsenz und nicht alle auf youtube
spezifisch spezifisch nicht dass
irgendwer sagte simon nein ich meine ich
sie mir ich liebe simon und deswegen das
auch gar nicht gegen sich gerichtet
warum habt ihr überhaupt erwähnt nur am
beispiel sieht man dass mir das letztens
aufgefallen dass da schon mal mit der
stress ein bisschen zu kopf steigt
deswegen schild einfach und bleibt
locker und gebt enorm hoch wenn ihr auch
so denkt dass youtube immer noch youtube
ist und nicht fernsehen wo man unter
druck steht und deswegen bleiben wir
alles so wie wir sind